welcome girls you drew today yeah uh how
do you feel uh jeans I will start with
you you had the top start yes
it's good not to lose you know yeah so I
feel of course I feel better
um yeah I think it's also important when
you lose the game it's just to make some
draw and you know just to feel this cold
yeah
sure
um so what about you Elizabeth did you
did you play the game in any way
differently knowing that Josiah started
with three losses do you think that okay
I have some chances to stay against her
or were you playing more cautiously
knowing that maybe
no well actually today I saw like I
should test her like how good is her
Theory knowledge
so I was choosing actually a lion where
like she has to be very accurate so I
was actually like checking a little bit
in the database and I saw finally
speaking a game between Arena crush and
vashali from the Olympiad and you know
when I uh saw the game in the database I
remember that I was even standing in
front of Arena sport at this moment when
I saw this position and then I was
thinking like okay
if she knows it then maybe like I should
have some emergency escape and the
Knight G5 is a normal move but instead
of Knight G5 Bishop G5 this is like what
I briefly checked today and I saw like
the engine gave like okay about equal
but it's not like that okay if I bring
my Bishop to E7 I should be kind of safe
so that's why I liked actually the move
Bishop G5 more than Knight G5 because
from the harmony of pieces was a little
bit like more safe let's say
and then yes I mean like like I think
she was surprised by Bishop G5
but uh well probably the position is
still too too easy in a way because
after Queen A6 I can have a castle
and then it was clear that at some point
if I want to win material she will
you know have some escaping
so would you like to comment on that
were you were you prepared very
surprised by Elizabeth yeah I mean okay
I also sold the game but I didn't know
Bishop G5 was
but after I saw Queen A6 and that she
couldn't Castle I was like okay it's
fine let's do it are you two also
friends in real life like
you know each other well of course you
play a lot of tournaments to tell your
friends too or may ask that question
yeah we're friends yes of course we're
friends there's a follow-up question to
that that's why I asked that question
first uh how tough is it to play against
a friend when you're playing such
important uh tournament it's really
tough I mean for me it's very tough I
like I always try to play you know like
some not not like not to push just to be
like normal Games
Without Really Trying you know no but
you know the thing is like when you play
a friend for example like in the first
round the bed against harika and she's a
good friend of mine I mean like Beyond
contact we are like sometimes helping
each other and like and she beat me in a
way like after five and a half hours
because of one single move and I even
saw the correct move in this game and
then I bet the wrong move and I lost
this game you know when you lose the
game and that despite the fact that this
is your friend or not you know like in
this moment you're saying like ah you
know like you know you're like you have
some kind of like like Angry feelings
with your opponent obviously but then
okay it's it's part of like our
profession we have to separate
friendship and professionalism and even
like losing to harika I mean like uh
it's not like I mean better to lose to a
friend that you lose to someone you
don't like in my opinion you know so so
I thought like okay I mean it's harika I
mean like she's my friend I mean she
even brought me something I asked her
like to bring something here which I
couldn't get in Germany and it was very
important for me to get and I could rely
her and she brought me this thing here
so why I should be now Angry with with
her because I met a silly silly move and
I lost the game because of that
so I can actually like we can separate
it also in the World Cup I I lost and
she's one of my closest friends
yes and it's not like going there it's
nice to I mean it's not nice but at
least you know that your friend is yes
yes yeah you prefer to lose to a friend
than to uh to lose to someone you don't
like at least for me especially at this
tournament there's no draw draw offers
allowed so you kind of but was it the
same like in 2019
I think like actually because of this
rule like probably Nana lost yesterday
in a way because the ending was
objectively a draw maybe they would not
have played on and maybe even in your
game at some point there would have been
a draw offer when the position became
absolutely I got the pawn right yeah
yeah I could have just yeah okay no so I
mean like I think actually it changes
some results uh in a way especially in
unclear positions they play it till the
end even so objectively it's a draw it
may change because of the energy level
for example yeah also like we're
checking sometimes for example if there
is some some complicated position and
your opponent has less of time and you
know that it's dangerous sometimes you
can just ask for a draw and you know
because they have less time they can
just agree and you're safe yes and I
mean like your opponent loses time
because he's thinking about that like
whether to take the draw or not and
sometimes actually like it's a kind of
psychology psychological parked so it's
very nice especially you play someone
weaker and you're a little bit in
trouble and you just like want to force
her now to decision whether to play on
or not then it's a perfect moment to ask
for a draw yeah especially if they are
like really close to that for the moon
yeah I love doing that yeah
all right let me give you a question
outside of the chess uh area for a
little bit and that question is if you
weren't a chess player
what profession would you choose to have
which one of you would like to answer
that first you go first well I know the
answer would be an opera singer opera
singer Yes actually it is but I've
watched a lot of you are uh yes in the
past I I had this hobby at some point
but then nowadays actually I wanted to
go into yodeling
and I even found the teacher but then
like you know I I get I got the lesson
with her and I wanted to continue and I
said to her like okay now I'm busy but
maybe next month and then she stopped
teaching because she had some personal
issues
so my dream of becoming a yodeler
actually disappeared in this moment and
I was a little bit upset because I saw
like okay next to Opera Singh your link
would be a nice technique to learn
interesting yeah so in order to make
jeans are less uncomfortable I will say
what I would like to be which would be
probably an actress okay yes no I think
I'll be the still a sportsman that I
don't know which sport boxing boxing or
swimming yeah
I love a lot of your your intense looks
I feel like you would you invigorate
with that too yes you can switch into
chess boxing it's popular nowadays so
it's gonna be my open and then well not
me because I'm not too weight class
unfortunately
I think it was uh Andrea bothas is
actually quite good yes yeah borders
against Dina was the more defensive one
and modus was like she was like so
active yes I mean I saw the video
actually Andrea also did another boxing
with someone else who was in the chess
player it wasn't a chess player it was
someone so maybe I would pick her no but
actually she would okay the scene is
like chest wise of course you're like
stronger than her but from the technical
point of view like what I really liked
about her when I saw this boxing matches
like that she was Fearless while I had
the impression that Dina was trying to
hide as much as she could because like
Andrea had this kind of impression like
I don't care I'll just teach you though
I will go and so I mean I really like um
okay I mean that's the first chance to
win no because she's a chess wise she
was like uh yeah yeah
stronger chest wise this is true I have
one more question and I'm gonna switch
it to what I asked you so this way
you'll not be prepared the question is
uh do you have a preference in which
chess pieces you're playing with
for example you know these way these
days
board pieces yeah but like do you have a
specific preference are you familiar
with the different ones that they are
you know there's the Fisher one I think
I like this one more than we have in the
venue now
yeah yeah
it's like a sound don't know like The
Challenge tournament one usually they
use this but now sounds in the shanton
or whatever sounds an area they use this
one these are the regular ones but now
and then now you play with heavier
pieces they're more heavy I checked the
weight yeah they're not good for Blitz
but for like classical chess they're
perfect but for Blitz I would even say
they might be too heavy
because I checked the weights because I
was feeling like when I was adjusting
the pieces like now in the chest clap
that the pieces are I mean the horsey
looks like very nice it has a very
specific look I mean you see like I
really study these pieces but I can see
that's good I'm glad my question didn't
just go on to like one but as I said for
Blitz it might be too heavy
a bit and at home when you prepare do
you care about what you're using or
you're just using the engines these days
uh
no I don't have you don't have a boy no
oh my God okay no why do you need it
because I'm not your age anymore so my
memory is not that good so like
something yeah
no but you know like when you repeat on
the screen it's not the same as if you
repeat on the board and sometimes I have
the feeling that I would forget it so
for example like today I checked like on
the board everything
because I would not remember like uh it
depends how deep you check on the
computer all the lines and you want me
to see on the board no but sometimes
especially like when you have to learn a
lot and when you have to look like for
the side moves and it's like and you
cannot like apply to Logics because
sometimes you have positions like
there's no logical thing at all so I
mean in order to to to memorize it you
have to get some kind of you know help
in a way to say to myself like it will
never happen on the board and then I'm
free so we have all generations I'm with
Elizabeth on this yes
I'm the conservative one you know I I do
carry a chessboard with me but I didn't
do it in your age but since like I'm 35
I saw it like I was getting abort when I
was like 10 8 Maybe
yeah
all right girls thank you so much for
all your time I wish you good luck for
the next one thank you thank you